all right so I'd like to call to order
the subcommittee work session on House
Bill 406
FN um relative to parental access to
Children's Medical Records uh the
purpose of this subcommittee work
session will be to make a recommendation
to the full health and human services in
Elder Affairs committee which will then
make a recommendation on the bill to uh
to the house when it reconvenes in
January um
so um I I guess I want to open by saying
I've had the benefit of of a number of
conversations with um Hospital cios uh
risk and compliance officers PRI privacy
and compliance officers um at some of
the healthc care providers in um in New
Hampshire and uh learned a lot
throughout this process and really
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
those folks um as the prime sponsor of
this
bill it's important to me uh that
we that we Empower parents and that we
get parents the information that they
need to um to to you know to be fully
informed about their their children's
health and well-being um having said
that I think we're also dealing with a
myriad of requirements both at the
federal and state level that make this a
much more complex issue than it appears
on the face of it um so um I I would
like to begin if I may by offering uh
just kind of a summary of what I've
learned throughout this process and and
and perhaps that will help to inform the
rest of the committee and in their
thoughts on where we go with this um
specifically uh the you know the the the
impetus for filing this bill arose from
a a parent who had received and many
parents have received a similar letter
um from one of the hospital systems in
New Hampshire uh saying that your child
is now aged 12 you will no longer have
access to their portal uh Records um and
this seemed to be a uh seemed to me and
to the parents in question uh to be be
kind of on an infringement on a parent
right to know what's happening with
their child um in
fact Hippa um dictates that parents do
have access to their children's me
medical records with certain
exceptions um those certain exceptions
might include things like um testing and
treatment for sexually transmitted
diseases among other things the same U
the same kinds of carve outs apply at
the state level
um in fact the
the the the ability to consent to
testing and
treatment for sexually transmitted
diseases is in New Hampshire statute um
for I'm pretty sure it's children e 16
and older um I may be wrong about that
maybe maybe 14 but I think it's 16 and
older and um and that also applies to
the privacy of those
records um that creates a bit of a
challenge for the uh for for the the
medical providers
because if they're going to provide
patient portal access they now need to
distinguish between that which is
accessible to the patient versus that
which is accessible to the parent um
that means that their systems need to
accommodate this kind of Patchwork of um
various treatments medic ations and um
tests that might occur throughout the
the course of of caring for for that
patient um for
example um if a if a doctor if a if a
16-year-old comes in and says I think I
may have a sexually transmitted disease
I want to get tested
um the test and the treatment may have a
flag in the record that says this is to
be this is to remain
private um the the the doctor or other
provider caring for that patient now
needs to check a box and make sure that
that is flagged as private from the
parents if they fail to do so it's a
compliance issue you know they they've
essentially violated the the privacy of
that of that minor
child
um and that was and and in the in the
conversation I had with a hospital C IO
the other day it was um it was possible
to flag the the
record um on treatment but not on
medication so there was no flag on
medication that the medication is to be
kept private
so ultimately there are there are
changes that need to happen at the
software level and the software um
typically we're talking about EMR EHR so
uh electronic medical records electronic
health records and these systems are
um as far as I know there are at least
eight different software vendors that
are in use in the state of New Hampshire
uh by various Hospital systems and
so they're they're they're not only
having to maintain those records they
also have portal software that then
needs to be able to
discern what to present to a parent
versus what to present to a child so
this puts the hospitals in a of All or
Nothing situation either we can present
everything or we can present nothing and
what they have chosen to do at this
point is to say starting at age 12 we're
going to present nothing to the parents
in order to comply with this Patchwork
of of uh privacy restrictions that are
in both fate federal and state
law
um
so I'll I'll stop there for a moment and
then I'll get into the information
blocking rule uh any questions or
comments so far yes
representative I should understand this
by now but it's I guess it just shows
how complicated it is um so you're
talking about the portal in particular
what information is available on the
portal but in in general in
principle
once I thought a minor was down to zero
but um I've just been informed that a
minor is 12 to
17 um and a child is younger than SE 12
um but in any case under federal law
under Hippa is it accurate to say
that a parent cannot access a 12 to 17
year old's records medical records
without consent from the
minor no that's not accurate it's um so
I was not trying to distinguish between
a child and a minor to me I was using
the terms interchangeably for anyone
under 18 um but the the distinction is
that they under Hippa a parent does have
the right to access their children's
medical records with certain exceptions
so if a if a parent goes to a a medical
provider and says I want a copy of my
child's Healthcare records They will get
them minus
certain things that are restricted so
okay that that was my previous
understanding but I guess maybe I
misunderstood something yeah and and the
problem is
that the EHR EMR systems and the portal
software that is used to make that
visible to to
patients is not able to
distinguish the you know what should be
excluded U for from a parent visibility
versus what should be
included
um
so the the other the other
um development that we were watching
when this bill was retained was what was
happening at the federal level with
something called the information
blocking Rule and the information
blocking rule um I believe emerged out
of the car's act and it basically says
that if a health care provider
has records that a patient is entitled
to
see and if the medical provider does
something let's say to make it more
difficult to access those records that
would be a a viol a violation of HIPPA
or the spirit of HIPPA and so um so the
information blocking rule was when we
rained this bill the information
blocking rule was still um sort of in
discussion how how will this look in
real life what are they going to
actually do um what will those
regulations look like there is a
specific carve out in what they have
implemented at the federal level
acknowledging the fact that there
are technical limitations currently in
the
software therefore the information
blocking rule has been deemed not to
apply currently to this situation that
is if if hospitals simply
say we're turn off parental access at
age 12 the the federal Regulators have
have acknowledged that the information
blocking rule will not apply uh will
will not prevent them from making that
decision because um there are technical
limitations which in essence compel them
them to make that
decision but but once again just so I
have this straight when you say turning
off access at age 12 you're talking
about turning off access to the portals
not to the actual information itself
turning yes turning off information to
the portal so let's let's I I'll maybe
give an example which is um let's say
you have a a 17-year-old who's going in
for um a routine
physical um or has you know breaks their
wrist or something like this and they're
going in for uh treatment and you around
the same time they go to a physician and
say hey I I I think I might have a
sexually transmitted disease I'd like to
get
tested the law dictates that parents
have access to the child's medical
record but the test for an STD or any
subsequent treatment for the STD is not
included in that so um in order for the
hospitals to comply with the law they
either have to
provide they have to filter the
information that's visible to a parent
using the
portal which is not currently
technically feasible for them um short
of spending many millions of dollars on
custom coding or um they need to say
look you know if you want your child's
medical record you need to come in and
request it and we will provide it to you
and when they provide it they're going
to pull out those things that are deemed
to be private they're going to pull out
the record about the testing for
STDs
okay any further questions about what
I've said yes representative kushman
thank you um so I have a few issues with
this um so having had worked with some
of these big um EMR systems like epic um
I know for a fact that it's very
possible for them to have the these
systems changed to comply with rules um
I remember I think it was in 2020 maybe
2021 there were some rules coming down
by October everything had to be switched
over and our um the person at the um
visiting nursing agency that I was
working at who works with epic was busy
working with them and and working at The
Kinks and figuring out what changes
needed to be made and you know it was
just accepted and they worked on
changing the um the software to comply
with the rules that were coming down and
they had like three months to do it so I
I I I sympathize with you know that that
takes some work but I know that these
systems are have the staff and you know
that um it's totally possible to come
into compliance with a law once it's
been enacted or when it when they know
it's going to be enacted soon um
so uh I could reach out to that person
and get a little bit more information
from her I would like to see exactly
what that process was for when they had
to change um that stuff and maybe get
some feedback for um the next time we
discuss this or the full committee or
what have you um so that is a little
Troublesome and and then just still the
idea that parents either have to have
you know parents who want to see their
kids chart through the or see their kids
information if the if the um hospital or
you know uh facility says um or doctor's
office says you know we're just going to
shut it off to you then that parent has
to go in person to and and get the
records in person and pay for the copies
and I know that we discussed that
already I don't think that that's a fair
burden to put on parents cuz I had a
call from a mom of nine you know who
wanted to get into her daughter's chart
and they would not give her any access
and this was on blood work she wanted to
know simple Labs what the labs results
were and the policy of the um doctor's
office was just no we don't allow you in
and then um I was also looking I I was
investigating this last night and you
know they've they've done um some
studies on these these emrs and over 50%
of them allow for pro proxy access um so
it's like deliberately designed to give
parents just the information that
they're entitled to over 50% of them
have that capability already so I just
don't see how it's so difficult maybe we
can push the the enactment date back to
give them some time to comply but um as
far as I see it you know saying oh we
don't have the technical ability and
just throwing their hands up it seems
like um it seems
like there's a lot more to it than that
and that it is possible maybe they just
need a little bit more time but that's
just my thoughts thank
you other comments
questions does any do any of our subject
matter experts in the room have anything
they'd like to
add
yes
thank you chairman um and members of the
committee for the record po inan senior
vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association I don't consider myself a an
expert but um I do represent the
hospitals and I have been um talking
with our our members for um months on
this so I appreciate representative
kushman um all all your excuse me
representative kofalt um as far as your
um um research that you have done in the
um willingness to talk with some of the
hospital um folks that has um I think
been very helpful certainly um the
hospitals have appreciated that as as
have I um I think um it is very
complicated um different systems um as
representative kushman mentioned epic is
a different system a very very expensive
system and not everyone has that um and
their capabilities are different than a
CNA versus a metatech or whatever else
um so that is one of the challenges um
and um they are all working towards this
but they are just not there yet um
relative to the portal and I I think I I
think I just need to um caution everyone
the EMR is not the portal and I think a
lot of people conflate the two um and
access to the miners medical record
through um the appropriate consents when
necessary are certainly um allowable
doable um happens all all the time um
and I think I have shared with the
committee through representative kofalt
some of the um uh documentation for for
doing just that it's the portal that I
think is just the issue that has um I
think been has come up during this whole
debate and I think pres kofalt has
explained it very well as far as it's an
extraction of the EMR and trying to pull
um without violating Hippa which would
be a federal um um problem um and
compliance is very very strict about
this um the chances of the flags we're
talking about human humans um putting
flags on and trying to make sure that
that data does not get over to the
portal inappropriately is is a big heavy
lift um and I um appreciate
representative kushman your comments but
um again epic is one system and not even
everyone that's on Epic has the same
capabilities because it is a lot of work
um and um the so what some hospitals
have done is actually shut off the
portal once the the patient turns 12 so
that they do not violate um Federal
HIPPA laws so um that so I just want to
mention that
um what we um certainly I think what has
come out of all of this is more
education I think which doesn't require
legislation um there is certainly always
an opportunity to um provide CL more
clarity to parents and to patients um in
general um and I think that is something
that we have taken back and will take
back and have further discussion
certainly with our hospitals relative to
what can be provided in uh Pediatric
rian's office in the hospitals um uh
offices um not just pediatricians but
family docs as well um so that it's very
clear what um the parents rights are and
what the patient's rights as a minor
child also are um so I just wanted to to
mention that as well but um again we we
cannot support this bill um because of
all the challenges and um um issues that
would be um um imposed if essentially
the hospitals um would not be able to to
meet these requirements um due to um
their the techn technological
limitations so what I think Could Happen
um is the portals would just get shut
off um and that's not good um the
portals I think are a great tool for
communicating with the provider with
setting up um uh appointments and um and
accessing all sorts of information
people really seem to like the portals
um but that that I'm afraid could be an
unintended consequence and that would be
really unfortunate so happy to answer
any questions there any
questions thank you for your perspective
thank you um yeah I just I guess I want
to comment on that last uh statement
which is um there are sometimes un
unintended con consequences to adding
requirements um
in New York City a number of years ago
for example um the the city passed an
ordinance that all swimming pools had to
have a um a lift for people with
disabilities to get in and out of the
pool um that was very costly ultimately
for hotels that had a swimming pool a
lot of those uh hotels simply decided to
close their swimming pool so uh there
are and and I'm not saying that's
necessarily what would happen here
um I ultimately think that this does
need to get resolved um I think that um
if we don't do it in a way that
is manageable and realistic then um you
know it could have unintended
consequences or it could prompt some
smaller providers to Simply go the route
of turning off P patient portals
altogether which I think would be a net
loss so um you know my my intention is
that you know I would like to see this
get resolved eventually um I I'm not um
in in my my comments I think are um are
if I hadn't said so already you know I I
I don't think that this bill is ready to
go to the floor for a vote in its
current form um having said that I I
think that it is an issue that we ought
to keep the pressure on um and and
hopefully see if if it can be resolved
at the federal level it if it can't be
resolved at the federal level then um
State legislation may be in order I just
don't personally feel like we're quite
there yet so um to me that suggests
either an itl or an interim study uh
motion but uh you know we'll have to see
what the other members of this working
uh committee subcommittee think about
that so um yes representative kosman
thank you so reading over the bill again
I don't see that it says anything
specifically about a portal and I know
we had talked about an amendment to do
that so um right now it looks like this
is just in line with the federal law
because it just says release of the
records to a parent or guardian and then
it has the carats for specific state or
federal laws or if there's a reason to
believe it may endanger the welfare of
the child um or if the parent agrees to
there being confidential communication
so the bill as it stands um it doesn't
really address that and I think it would
just I what it looks like to me is that
it would put in our state law a
guarantee that a parent can access their
child's record and whether that's in
paper or the
portal the way it's written now it's
really up to who's providing the record
to the parent um unless a parent asks
specifically for paper you know what I
mean do you understand what I'm saying
like it doesn't say it just says that
they need access to the
record so under Hippa they already have
that so if the parent asks um you know
their child's doctor for that
information um and the the doctor's
office uses a um patient portal that
doesn't have the ability to let the
parent in um without hiding that
sensitive information then they have to
furnish a paper copy of the record um
but that's what it looks like your bill
does right now now just you know
enshrines that in state law I just
wanted to make that comment that's all I
don't know what that means for the
outcome of this subcommittee but just
wanted to mention it okay representative
Shapiro thank you
um you know aside from all of the
technical challenges in terms of the
portals and electronic medical records
which seem to be significant enough to
um to be cautious about passing a bill
like this um I'm also concerned that
um we're waiting into something that's
just not necessary that
um that Hippa already
outlines
um what parents have access what
guardians or parents have access to in
terms of medical
information and
um we're coming at this bill initially
from from a place of assuming that
there's a significant problem because of
an anecdotal letter
from I shouldn't say a real letter from
a hospital that was maybe more
complicated than we thought it was at
first um because when I heard you read
that I thought it was denying parents
access
um and so I would also say that
um I just don't think this is necessary
and we're kind of waiting into a a
battle where one side assumes that uh
medical providers are keeping
information from families
and
um I guess I just don't think it's
necessary so I would support an
itl
okay yes I I agree I support an itl I
think they were looking for a problem
that is not that significant there may
be some issues with this but I think
basically if my child is having some
kind of a medical procedure I should
just have access to that okay and so I
think that this is kind of prohibitive
in my access to things
that so thank you I um
so you know my my own comment about sort
of is there a problem is I believe that
there is a problem for multiple reasons
one is that it's it's somewhat alarming
for a parent to receive that letter um
and it's not just one hospital system
that's doing it it's you know I I I have
suggested that you know perhaps some
further explanation of why this is being
done uh may help to alleviate some of
that alarm because it it it seems that
um the medical providers are kind of
being in put in a position where they
have to be the bad guy and that's
actually not the way I see it now uh the
way I see it now is that they're subject
to regulation which kind of put them in
a no in situation um I would like to see
this
resolved um I would you know whether we
do itl or or interim study or whether
someone proposes an amendment to the
full committee I would like to
ultimately see this move forward my
sense is that um there
is the ideal place for it to move
forward is at the federal level
or at the you know at the software
companies that are that are doing this
and I don't see them necessarily
investing that until somebody tells them
they have to um so I guess my my
inclination is to say you know I I don't
want to let this issue die um but I it
it occurs to me that the the bill this
may not be the right time for the bill
and certainly the um the short time
frame for implementation is just not
feasible I I believe at this
point
yes representative I lost my question
but my question has to do with having
this resolve studying us and trying to
to change are we able to do that or we
better to just itl and start new with a
new
proposals you know per personally that's
what I would intend to do um if if this
gets
itls any further discussion
yes representative kushman just um just
to like kind of tie up the the ends of
what I was saying um so that
parent um she has nine children she had
to she went to look up the labs she
couldn't see them that her daughter had
had just routine Labs but she um wanted
to know what the results were she called
the doctor's office they said no she's
12 you don't have access to her portal
anymore if you want the records you have
to come in in person and get them on
paper so that's that would comply with
this law um or this bill and it complies
with HIPPA
um however um I called that office and
discussed it with their office manager
and shortly thereafter the parent had
access to the record um so I think it's
very
possible if we hold people's feet to the
fire to respect parentals right parental
rights and that you know it can be done
um I understand that there are
definitely technical challenges and that
that's going to take some time um
because this doesn't really specifically
address the portal issue and it just
basically restates Hippa I'm comfortable
with an itl okay um and I and I support
um bringing another bill back you know
watching this issue seeing what happens
and if necessary bringing a bill back
with a lader half
date all
right yes we have a motion
representative Fus representative fedus
Mo makes a motion uh to recommend
inexpedient to legislate do we have a
second uh representative Shiro
seconds any further
discussion all right um we'll we'll uh
vote on the motion then representative
Shapiro yes representative kushman yes
representative
fedus and I vote Yes as well um that is
a four to nothing vote on
itl motion passes is there any further
discussion yes representative Shapero I
I would just like to say this a you know
when we're talking about medical records
there's a great variation of information
and
um I would be frustrated if I was a
parent and I was not able if there was a
real barrier put in front of me in terms
of getting lab tests for uh how old she
was 13 13 year old um on the other hand
um in my career as a mental health
clinician
um you know I I I passionately believed
in informed consent and parent parental
involvement I thought of myself as a
family um therapist um and yet at the
same time there were often delicate
issues that were
um were were were were're providing
information um was incredibly delicate
and um I I was glad to be able to have
some control of how that information was
um shared and I spent you
know infrequently with with not very
many people but throughout my career
spent a lot of time hours with parents
going over their medical records in my
office uh their their children's medical
records in my office um you know Page by
page because I thought if that could be
avoided it was probably better
but um when it was necessary it was
really important to do and um so I guess
I just want to say that um while I voted
to itl I'm I'm a believer that parents
um should be involved um to get the best
results for their
kids fully agreed thank you any further
discussion okay with that I thank
everyone for their uh for their members
for their uh membership in this work
working subcommittee uh thank you for
your attendance today and I will close
the hearing thank
you